alors il ya un jeu qui était très
célèbre c'était la tête et les jambes
rappelé représentée par pierre bellemare
donc je vais poser des questions à
nabila et si nabila ne répond pas il y
aura des épreuves un petit peu physique
pour chacun d'entre nous on est attendu
abbassi bas si je vous le dis c'est la
ligue à la télé on ne sait pas en fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention on va de jouer pour thierry
mots pour la première pierre yves moreau
alors allez-y
s'il vous plaît vous allez jouer pour
des pompes à la chantilly vous allez
devoir faire des pompes avec isabelle
assises petit peu sur vous mais palpable
pas beaucoup 1 il y aura de la chantilly
juste en dessous d'accord les pompes à
la chaux qui est ce qu'on peut mettre la
chantilly s'il vous plaît ce qu'on peut
allez-y je vais poser la première
question à nabila ben metella parquet
remercie mais il met sa tête
voilà exactement thierry moreau
mettez-vous en place mon chéri c'est
pour cette dernière
oui bah y'a pas besoin de trois
assiettes une arrestation qui a annoncé
sur la liberty bercy mais après une
dernière bah oui aller à elle veut pas
celle de la chantilly
j'ai compris bravo mais dit bravo non on
va pas mettre isabelle morini bosc est
juste le faire comme ça bien sûr
attention là on attendait j'y réponds
pas mon sixième et sereine var et ondées
sur ménard attention vous n'avez
peut-être répond diop les personnes de
soupe
voici millas compte sur vous voici la
question qui a pop
la joconde exposée au musée du louvre la
joconde
nabila vous avez trois secondes dit
n'importe quoi sinon la villa cahors
picasso non mais il apporte ici
puis il n'a pas la relève picasso c'est
léonard de vinci bien sûr attention 5
pompe bien sûr shanty town avec mérite
pas l'honneur en bas en bas complètement
mais non je parle est la tête de l'eau
ce qu'il veut si je réussissais on
reprend à merci deux hypers
voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'était facile attention voici la
deuxième on joue nabila on joue pour
gilles gilbert dette
ils doivent manger un piment et chantier
a allumé le feu a porté le pima s'il
vous plaît le piment le piment merci
d'amener vélines venait allez on y va
merci le piment mercy au malawi
ça me rappelle quelque chose de tout un
morceau de piment oui oui oui bah oui
mais alors vous croquez redressement en
dire moins attention nabila voici la
question tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à
la fin elle est au quoi quoi
davila tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la
fin mais posez moi la question c'est
quoi c'est l'expression l'expression
c'est quoi alors on va la cruche à l'eau
qu'à la fin
faites-moi leur nana na na na nana na na
je sais pas si c'est une émission
j'essaie france envoie là ce avait pas
de temps réel tous à l'eau tant va la
cruche à l'eau qu'à la fin elle tombe à
l'eau eh bien tant va la cruche à l'eau
qu'à la fin elle se casse elle se brise
et bien gilles verdez vous devez chanter
allumer le feu en plus un bon ok pas
trop ce qu'on apprenne que vous êtes je
fais beaucoup d'affection détient encore
et toujours des questions c'est
dérangeant
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît voici la
prochaine question joue pour enora et
nohra mais t'es bon s'il vous plaît mais
si en place qu'est ce que vous allez
vous mettre à vous mettre à côté de neuf
je connais pas la réponse est à côté de
nabila bizzzouxxx si vous perdez nabila
ou devra affronter et nos rangs au bras
de fer
quelle est la capitale de l'australie
la lave et à le dire bah vous avez perdu
allez venez là vous allez ici venez
venez l'algérie je céderai trouve la
capitale de l'australie c'est canberra
bien sûr brad sociaux c'était moi j'ai 0
c'est parti on peut refaire on refait
c'était bien mais là trop de patates à
la troupe patate c'est la tâche aux non
merci la vie la balle elle soit pour les
deux sens à donner des jouets lors d'une
de deux sur voici la dernière c'est pour
jean michel maire jean michel maire
sachez qu on joue on joue je vous le dis
pour faire un smack à jean michel maire
là c'est pas pareil les règles de chance
si vous répondez mal vous faites un
smack à jean michel bouat c'est abuser
ça si vous répondez bien vous ne faites
pas de ce mac à jean michel mr d'accord
bas aussi la question avec la longue à
un smack langue halle st jacques le gall
oui ou non mais ça se fait pas
ça revient taille
nabila voici la question donc si vous
répondez bien pas de smac tension
concentrez vous bien la question est
plutôt facile s'il vous plaît sert elle
une bonne question n'inquiétait pas je
serai toujours là la question c'est bon
facile ou aîné jean michel mr bah jean
michel mary déni ou là je sais quoi
annoncer nancy à nancy nancy
vous êtes né ou jean michel six
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passez à côté michel